l'australie valide le vaccin russe pour
les voyageurs après l'arabie saoudite ou
encore israël récemment canberra donc
accepter les les voyageurs qui seraient
vacciner avec le vaccin spoutnik v le
ministre australien de la santé a
déclaré avoir obtenu de moscou des
informations fondées selon lesquelles le
vaccin réduit ray les formes graves
ainsi que la transmission du virus à un
moindre degré ont fait le point sur
place avec notre correspondant antoine
claires au regard des
bonnes nouvelles pour les vacciner au
spoutnik v et plus globalement pour la
reconnaissance internationale du vaccin
russe il est désormais reconnu par les
autorités australiennes ces dernières
cherchent ainsi à favoriser le retour
des étudiants travailleurs business mail
est sportif de haut niveau vers le pays
l'attention des médias s'est récemment
focaliser sur le cac novak djokovic mais
une joueuse russe natalia ni rien ça va
n'avait pu se rendre à melbourne pour
participer aux qualifications de l'open
d'australie parce qu'elles étaient
vaccinés uniquement aux boutiques vais
non encore reconnue alors moscou
accueille donc très favorablement la
reconnaissance du vaccin par l'australie
l'un des premiers pays occidentaux à
l'accepter la liste des pays qui ont de
facto reconnu le vaccin russe spoutnik v
ne cesse de s'élargir aujourd'hui c'est
l'australie qui l'a rejointe cela
témoigne clairement de la reconnaissance
de l'efficacité du vaccin russe foot
nick v à l'étranger pendant ce temps
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
poursuit son processus d'examen de
spoutnik vais tous les documents
demandés ont été remis à partir de
février l'inspection des sites de
production pourra commencer la réponse
finale est quant à elle attendue avant
mi 2022 concernant le processus
d'acceptation par l' agence européenne
des médicaments
il est suspendu à une dernière condition
le centre gamaleya qui a mis au point le
vaccin on est au stade de
l'harmonisation des standards de
production avec les exigences du
régulateur européen un an et demi après
son enregistrement spoutnik v continue
donc son chemin vers sa reconnaissance
internationale